ce sont des images captées un petit peu
plus tôt ce soir sur le belvédère du
mont royal à montréal où se déroulait la
commémoration du drame de polytechnique
sonné le 6 décembre 89 qui avait coûté
la vie à quatorze femmes donc quatorze
victimes 14 faisceau lumineux qui se
dressent dans le ciel la cérémonie s'est
déroulée en présence de la mairesse
valérie plantes et de l'invité spécial
sophie grégoire trudeau la femme de
justin trudeau s'implique auprès de
nombreuses organisations de lutte pour
le droit et l'égalité des femmes depuis
de nombreuses années elle a d'ailleurs
livré l'été dernier discours à l'onu
à l'occasion d'une conférence sur les
filles et le leadership
elle était de passage sur notre plateau
un peu plus tôt bonsoir se fie aux
intrus doubienne 24 soit sans merci au
moment d'enregistrer cet entretien en
milieu d'après midi
on est à peine à une heure de cette
cérémonie commémorative de polytechnique
où vous avez joué un rôle vous vous êtes
jointe à madame plantes notamment pour
rendre hommage à ses quatorze victimes
si vous voulez bien on va regarder
ensemble
l'hommage qu'on lui rende ce trou d'où
ce matin en chine aux victimes de
polytechnique ont écoulé dix ans j'étais
moi-même au cégep quelques coins de rue
de cette soirée qu'on n'oubliera jamais
ça m'a amené à être
beaucoup plus présent
j'espère pour le restant de ma vie
réfléchir et à travailler pour contrer
pile
pas
c'est un fléau la violence faite aux
femmes c'est présent partout sur la
planète ces présents ici au dans notre
pays ici aussi dans notre province dans
toutes les provinces
elle prend les formes subtiles 1 dans
notre quotidien et des fois c'est
vraiment en pleine vue mais il faut
absolument la dénoncer partager nos
histoires de souffrance quand ça vient à
la violence à la violence faite aux
femmes et aux filles et c'est le seul
moyen de guérir le partager nos
histoires et de commémorer le massacre
l'assuré la polytechnique sinon non
seulement de se rappeler de ces villes
qui ont été perdus des familles qui ont
été détruites des mamans des papas qui
souffrent encore des familles entières
qui souffrent mais de l'importance de de
dénoncer les inégalités dans une société
et la violence envers les femmes et les
filles fondée sur le sexe est une
réalité au quotidien convient je vais
vous vécu vos moindres sur la violence
ou l'inégalité
je donne une égalité oui parce qu'il y
en a encore des inégalités dans notre
société
heureusement j'ai pas j'ai pas su faire
d'agression sexuelle j'ai des amis qui
ont été atteintes et tellement
d'histoires autour de nous qui sont
faciles à entendre et difficile à
soutenir qu'il faut dénoncer
[Musique]
écoutez j'avais quoi elle avait
14 ans je me souviens plus où j'étais
mais je me souviens d'avoir senti
beaucoup de confusion à ce moment là on
parlait pas de temps que ça de la
violence envers les filles et la femme
de manière commune de manière épidémique
il y avait du cas par cas on entendait
des choses ici et là on n'était pas
branché sur les réseaux sociaux ni à
toute l'information qui circule comme
l'est aujourd'hui
mais je me souviens d'avoir ressenti
beaucoup de confusion voyons donc
un homme s'en est pris à des femmes
parce qu'elles étaient des femmes et
c'est encore comme ça aujourd'hui les
femmes ont leur on leur enlève leurs
droits fondamentaux
elles sont bafouées sur tellement de
niveaux qui qui détruit au niveau moral
psychologique spirituel sociétale
économique
alors on n'a qu'à gagner à éduquer non
seulement les tous les citoyens mais
aussi les garçons et les hommes qui sont
des êtres magnifique avec un potentiel
incroyable sur ce que c'est que de
rendre hommage à la femme au quotidien à
la main et au quotidien mais je pense
que vous ne mentionnez les hommes on
vient de voir monsieur trudeau pour vous
les hommes font partie de la solution
le 8 mars vous avez voulu impliquer les
hommes ça va vous avez une petite
controverse à ce moment là un milieu ça
fait jaser il faut que les hommes et les
garçons fasse partie de cette équation
on découvre un 1er mai pendant longtemps
qu'on entre nous qu'on vous parle pas de
politique mais quand même l'homme qu'on
a découvert au fil de certaines semaines
certains mois à l'occasion d' excuses un
homme sensible qui versent des larmes et
s'est fait sujet d' analyse même de
caricatures ça devient parce que
politique mais pour vous qu'est ce que
ça représente de le voir émue aux larmes
c'est moi qui vont en avoir mais ça
représente tout des dents une travail si
demandant sérieux de prendre les
décisions importantes et sérieuse pour
une population
il faut aussi être empli d'humanité vous
savez notre grand reng nous on prend
beaucoup décision basée sur les faits la
recherche la science et non ce que on
pense qu'ils correct coûts ce qui
devrait être considéré donc c'est
important de toujours et que l'intention
réside toujours dans l'humanité de la
personne et il est grand temps qu'on
s'unisse en tant qu'être humain dans
notre humanité et d'arrêter de faire des
différences justement entre les hommes
et les femmes donc chaud c'est très
important
quelqu'un qui était en prise décisionnel
qui a un impact sur la société est
capable d'être remplis d'humanité de
compassion et d'empathie et je pense
qu'on élève nos enfants comme ça aussi
là vous en parlez à vos enfants ben
c'est certain et oui oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas nous aussi que
le time magazine la personnalité de
l'année c'est ce groupe de femmes
on va peut-être voir des images là les
les buzzer de silence dans des voies ça
c'est important
moi je trouve ça que c'est ce n'est que
ce soit plus qu'une femme qui soit sur
la couverture parce que
m
on doit se réunir pour on doit s'unir et
on doit ce supporter dans l'avenant dans
nos souffrances dans l'eau dans nos
histoires personnelles et il faut porter
un langage de respect plus de compassion
les unes envers les autres pour se
soutenir s'assurer que les femmes se
sentent libres et en sécurité de parler
et de dénoncer ceux qui le plus
important parce que toutes ces femmes
ans et une femme
vous allez donc et à cette cérémonie
tout à l'heure il se peut que vous
rencontriez des victimes de la famille
des victimes de politiques nés qui ont
encore des revendications l'autre jour
sur le plateau de 4,60 je recevais
nathalie pour vous parce que l'on que
moyen de différentes choses devraient
entendre un extrait on milite pour ça
même avec ottawa pour essayer de
remettre certains contrôles évidemment
c'est très bien qu'on rebâtir pas un
registre fédéral
mais pour moi de plusieurs zones
dangereuses blizzard dangereuse existe
déjà des enregistrements et seul le
gouvernement fédéral n'a pas enrayé
d'autres armes dangereuses qui sont pas
un registre hypothèque en fait l'enjeu
dans que vous soulignez là c'est tout
l'enjeu de la classification des armes
donc qu'est-ce qui est une arme non
restreint qu'est-ce qui est une arme
prohibée qu'est-ce qui est une arme
restreinte cette classification là les
critères qui existent sont des critères
très anciens qui font qu'aujourd'hui la
grc quant à fès est la signification la
haye l'a pas les outils pour pouvoir
retirer du commerce beaucoup plus aisé d
ambre quasi militaire je veux dire comme
maman je réagis parce qu'évidemment que
je veux pas que les gens se retrouvent
avec des armes qui est qui qui peuvent
faire mal c'est clair et c'est aussi un
dossier comme femme d'un politicien que
je sais que le gouvernement prend
extrêmement au sérieux
on est très différent quant à notre
approche par rapport aux armes à feu du
gouvernement précédent mais je sais que
il se penche sur ce dossier là et au
cours des prochains mois sinon année
pendant la prochaine année il va avoir
des annonces sur ce dossier là mais vous
savez tout ce qui touche à la violence
fondée sur le sexe c'est quelque chose
qu'on prend extrêmement au sérieux au
sein de notre gouvernement
les 100 millions qui était annoncé sur 5
ans par la milice moncef par rapport à
tout ce qui touche à la violence fondée
sur le sexe tout ce qui touche à offin
qui sont mentionnés des situations
vulnérables le ministre jean yves duclos
pour les familles a annoncé 40 milliards
sur dix ans on engendre beaucoup
d'action et du concret avec des choux
pour s'assurer que la situation précaire
des femmes et des filles au pays et
présent ce plan d'aidé surtout pour par
exemple nathalie provost qui elle est
une survivante parce qu'elle était
blessée elle même
c'est une des survivantes on l'a vu sur
civière elle avait lavé reçu des balles
donc elles demandent justement est ce
que l demand c'est dans cet entre
villacastin qu'on a pris du recul par
rapport à 1989 à cause justement de la
case ilebo circulation d'armes est quasi
militaire dont quelque chose d'à côté
parce qu'elle n'était pas en position
dans les 10 dernières années mais sachez
que c'est un sujet qu'on prenne des
noces à lui et je les encourage à
continuer à hausser sa voix très bien
alors pour l'avenir votre rôle vous le
voyez comment vous parce que j'ai eu un
débat il y en eu en france il y en a
partout et celui aux états unis
et au canada ça a été un peu trancher
n'est pas de rôle officiel ici au canada
je ne vois pas ma vie comme un euro je
vois ma vie comme ma vie c'est sophie si
je suis maman trois enfants je suis la
femme de justin j'ai des responsabilités
nous en tant qu'être humain est la cause
de la femme et les inégalités des
enfants ça me tient à coeur depuis
longtemps bien avant qu'on prenne le
chemin politique
alors je vais continuer sur cette voie
là avec beaucoup d'intégrité et puis je
me sens privilégié d'avoir une
plateforme plus grande pour pouvoir on
rendrait plus d'action et de commères et
comme parents devant les récents
événements de vendre une commémoration
comme polytechnique comment le mouvement
mais aussi avec garçons et filles à la
maison bien encore tout petit mais est
ce que ça change votre façon de les
aborder est ce que ça nourrit votre
éducation éducation à leur endroit
mais je pense que tous les parents qui
nous écoutent qui vous écoute son accord
que nos paroles sont importants mais nos
jets sont d'autant plus importants
comment est ce qu'on pense de la mère
des filles des femmes au sein de notre
propre famille
comment est-ce qu'on en parle à l'école
dans notre environnement travail les
gens peuvent avoir un impact immense que
par des petites actions qui leur langage
sur comment se considère en tant qu'être
humain que le reste et comporte d'un
homme une femme et vice versa alors moi
je trouve ça encourageant de savoir que
tout le monde a ce pouvoir là de changer
la dynamique et le déséquilibre entre
hommes et femmes pour faire une société
plus juste plus équitable plus
harmonieuse en terminant je suis que
vous avez rencontré récemment madame
obama michelle obama elle revient favori
qu'est ce qu'elle représente pour vous
michel représente une femme de tête
une mère de famille aimante engagé et
une être un être humain ancré à l'ecoute
est bien dans sa peau je pense que cette
hausse plus que j'ai vu que j'avais des
projets avec mélanie à tout impôt si sûr
non non j'ai pas d'après des projets
concrets mais quand ça vient au trafic
humain c'est sûr que ça me touche moi
aussi j'ai déjà entendu prononcer ces
mots là dans un discours mais sinon on
n'y a pas de projet concret en ce moment
et bien jouer juste vous allez faire en
février quand elle va venir à montréal
je l'espère beaucoup de déplacements
mais je vais te faire se figurer contre
double merci d'être venu aujourd'hui je
vous laisse filer cette cérémonie où on
verra l'élimination de 14 faisceau
lumineux création de mon même facture
qui rappelle mon après spirituel
l'évocation de ces quatorze femmes
tombées il y avait du temps j'ai hâte
d'y être avec le coeur ouvert